ليس بعيدا عن موسكو مئه كيلو متر فقط
تتوغل مسيره الاوكرانيه محمله بالمتفجرات
لتضرب مدينه كرييفسك وبينما التزمت
اقرت سلطات الروسيه بوقوع انفجار وسقوط
اصابات
وبمواساه هذا التطور اللافت يصر بوتين على
نقل اسلحه النوويه الى بيلاروسيا خطوه
يراها الغرب بالغه الخطوره وسيكون لها ما
بعدها
فقد اعلنت خدمه الطوارئ في مدينه تولا
الروسيه عن اصابه ثلاثه اشخاص جراء انفجار
وقع في مدينه كاريير بمقاطعه تولى الروسيه
واكد ممثل عن خدمه الطوارئ في تصريحات
لوكاله
محمله بالمتفجرات تسببت في هذا الانفجار
واشار المصدر الى ان هذه المسيره من طراز
141 سارز وتتبع للقوات الاوكرانيه
نقلا عن سلطات انقاذ انفاذ القانون في
روسيا قولها ان المسيره من طراز
وهي تابعه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
لمناقشه هذا التطور معنا من عمان لواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
لواء فايز الدويري هذا الهدف على بعد 200
كيلو متر من موسكو نريد ان نتعرف منك على
دلاله هذه الضربه
ودلاله الموقع المتقدم القريب من موسكو
يعني هذه هي المره الثالثه التي تستهدف
المنطقه التي تقع الى الجنوب من موسكو
سواء في انجلز او في سارتوف وهذه المنطقه
يوجد بها قواعد جويه
وعندما تم في شهر ديسمبر مهاجمه احد هذه
القواعد انجلز تحديدا كان الهدف في تلك
الغاره طائرات
الطائرات القادمه في الاستراتيجيه
160 وتعرض
اشرطه فيديو لاحقا من مصادر متعدده اثبتت
انه حدث اصابات بعدد من هذه الطائرات
وبالتالي هذه المنطقه ينتشر بها العديد من
القواعد العسكريه وهي منطقه يفترض انها
مؤمنه من خلال شبكات التشويش العام بحيث
لا تستطيع
الصواريخ او الطائرات اجتيازها
كيف نفهم القدرات العسكريه الروسيه التي
لم تمنع وصول هذه المسيره الاوكرانيه الى
هذا العمق
هذه نقطه جدليه يعني عندما يتم استهداف
اهم ميناء عسكري
لاكثر من مره بطائرات مسيره على نفس
المكان هذا يعني وجود ثغره في منظومه
الدفاع الجوي هذه الطائره تحديدا التي
نفذت اخر عمليه
هذه دخلت الخدمه في عام 79 وكانت تعتبر
فخر الصناعه السوفيتيه في تلك الفتره
لماذا للميزات التي تعملها سرعه تصل الى
1000 كلم 1200 كيلو متر مدى 1000 كلم
الطيران على ارتفاع سته كيلو مترات مزوده
بقياس مع تلك الفتره بكاميرات رقميه
بامكانيات وقدرات تشويش لا تستطيع منظومات
الدفاع الجوي العاديه
ولا الرادارات اكتشافها او التعامل معها
انا اتحدث في تاريخ الصنع لكن الان
منظومات عش 300 اس 400 تتعامل معها ويمكن
اكتشافها لكن هناك ثغره معينه وبالتالي
لاحظ تم استهداف هذه المنطقه اربع مرات
بطبغارات جويه هذه ليست يعني اخر مره كان
هناك هجوم اوكراني في العمق الروسي كما
تفضلت ربما ثلاث مرات وكان هناك رد روسي
لافت في ذلك الوقت كيف يمكن ان تتوقع
الرد الروسي على هذه الضربه الاوكرانيه
يعني الرد الروسي هو بيكون
بوسيلتين الوسيله الاولى استخدام طائرات
شاهد المسيره او استخدام الصواريخ كاليبر
تحديدا او اسكندر ولكن بالامس كان هناك
تقرير من احد وكالات الانباء ذات
المصداقيه واستنادا على معلومات من داخل
اوكرانيا ان القدرات الصاروخيه لروسيا لا
تستطيع ان تنفذ اكثر من 50 الى 70 صاروخ
خلال ال 24 ساعه فيما كانت الارقام اكبر
من ذلك بكثير فمن المتوقع ان يتم مهاجمه
اهداف والاهداف تحديدا ستكون اهداف الطاقه
اللواء فايز الدويريه الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي متحدثا من عمان لواء فايز
دويري شكرا لك على الافاده